So today, we've talked about formal
logic in order to set up a kind of
formal language for
us to reason with going forward.
We started off by talking about formal
notation, including conjunctions and
disjunctions, so that we can
write sentences in formal logic.
We use that to then talk
about truth tables, and
exam some of the properties that we need
going forward, like De Morgan's law.
Using that,
we investigated some of the inferences
that we can draw using formal logic.
And finally, we looked at proof by
reputation which kind of capitalizes on
everything we've talked about so far.
Next time, we'll be discussing planning,
which leverages the formal logic
that we've developed in this lesson.
It allows agents to reason more
formally about initial and goal states.
Interestingly, planning actually has its
history in the kinds of proofs we've
developed here.
Originally, agents would prove that
a particular plan would work, so
that's why we talk about formal
logic before we talk about planning.